gal gadot shares a sweet moment with a
young Wonder Woman fan in cosplay she is
such an amazing role model female
superhero role model for girls and boys
and I love everything about her
[Music]
because our sacred duty to defend the
world and it's what I'm going to do
while gal signed autographs
amid the san diego comic-con madness one
adorable little girl dressed as Wonder
Woman appear to tear up meeting the
actress who plays her favorite superhero
in the clip shared by variety you can
see gals Justice League co-stars Ezra
Miller Jason Momoa and Ben Affleck
admiring the touching exchange and we
can't help but melt
I've been what you say a Wonder Woman
the girl's mother Christine Keller
shared on Facebook how much the moment
meant to her daughter Ashley writing
what a great role model and genuine nice
person
my daughter will always remember this
moment for the rest of her life
really heartwarming people are very very
excited about the Wonder Woman movie
[Music]